protests against the proposed judicial
overhaul have been continuing in Israel
despite prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu delaying plans to push through
legislation public anger has led to a
general strike and seen thousands of
Israelis take to the streets opponents
accused Netanyahu of a power grab saying
the changes will give the ruling
Coalition unchecked power Natasha
grename reports from West Jerusalem
in the face of protests growing by the
day
A reversal by a prime minister not known
for compromise
from a national responsibility from the
will to avoid the rift within the people
I decided to suspend the second and
third reading from the law in this
knesset tenure in order to give time to
get to a broad consensus to pass the
Legislation during the next knesset
Benjamin Netanyahu gave way as the
country faced growing paralysis with a
nationwide strike closing airports
schools Banks and businesses tens of
thousands filled the streets to voice
their frustrations
we're fighting for this tradition for
this attempt to overthrow the Judiciary
and take control by the politician will
be thrown away from the table and we're
also asking that Benjamin Netanyahu will
resign and take responsibility for what
he has done to this country but
netanyahu's delay came with a price
Hardline national security minister
idamar Ben gavir said his party only
agreed to the delay in exchange for the
formation of a new National Guard under
the command of Ben gevir's office
there were divisions within the ruling
Coalition some called for uniting behind
Netanyahu to Halt the judicial overhaul
and Defuse The Crisis others dug in
saying they would not surrender to
Violent Anarchy and the tyranny of the
minority
the far-right governing Coalition and
supporters say they will not have the
vote or the state stolen from them I
think it is a tremendous mistake to stop
the reform however I can understand
because of the Heat of the Moment and
the fighting that's going on he has to
make a calculated decision
but but the reform is an absolute
necessity for this country to continue
in a democratic fashion left unresolved
the post of Defense Minister it was
netanyahu's firing of yoav Galant on
Sunday that brought the crisis to a head
as of Monday evening galat had not
received a formal dismissal letter
Netanyahu has 48 hours to name a
successor
West Jerusalem
well let's get more on this now we're
joined by Dan arbell he's a former
Israeli Diplomat and Scholar at the
center for Israeli studies at the
American University and he's joining us
live from Washington DC thank you very
much for your time do you think that
this delay to the reforms will lead to
any negotiations any compromise between
the government and opposition parties
uh I'm expecting negotiations to begin
in the next few days between
representatives of the government and
representatives of the opposition
however
um you know these negotiations don't
it's not very promising the gaps are
wide as it would be very hard to reach a
broad base of agreement over the
proposal and so the we should give it a
chance there is a chance that it would
succeed but then I think I would be very
cautious in saying uh it will be there
will be a breakthrough anytime soon is
there anything short of scrapping these
reforms that would be enough for those
opposed to it
so among those who oppose it you have
the members of parliament uh leaders of
the opposition that are that have vowed
and therefore are delivering on their
promise to enter negotiations within the
Netanyahu government on the other side
you have
leaders Ordinary People leaders of the
protest movement who are not willing to
make any compromise until the proposal
is shelved
um and so uh there is a divide there and
it's going to be interesting to see how
that unfolds the protest movement is not
going anywhere and it will continue the
question is whether the representative
the opposition right they're aligned
protesters would be uh willing to make
any compromises and the protest say that
they're not going anywhere because the
proposed reforms are a threat to the to
the state of Israel to the idea of a
democratic Israel and so that's why they
say that they can't compromise on this
do you think they have a point
but they they uh they all have very
valid points the question is what's
realistic at this point uh Netanyahu
right now has a 64 seat majority in the
knesset and um he's not he is not uh
willing to uh compromise at this point
on on that he's not stepping down and so
the question is is it realistic to
demand his stepping down I don't know if
it's if it can work uh definitely
Netanyahu has fractured the nation he's
definitely caused a lot of damage the
level of trust in his leadership is very
low and I think uh you know the the next
few days will be critical in determining
the direction of where this is going 6
64 is a very slim majority in a 120
member knesset isn't it Mr arbell do you
see anyone in netanyahu's coalition
government taking away their support for
these reforms
right now they're pretty United behind
him uh the question will be in the
coming days how that there are voices of
some voices that are calling him to
soften the proposal to make compromises
those are a very slim minority within
the Coalition and it's not entirely sure
whether he needs 61 to pass this and so
so far he has it whether there will be
three or four or five that will switch
to the other side or just abstain it's
an open question right now and as you
say the next few days few weeks are
crucial do you think that the the delay
could take the steam out of the protest
movement do you think that that's what
prime minister Netanyahu is hoping for
that's definitely what he's hoping for
but the the way I see uh the protest
movement is very energized and is very
determined and I don't think they're
going anywhere and therefore I believe
that netanyahu's hopes are uh he are are
just false hopes uh they're not uh he
will not be able to dissolve this
protest movement that's my opinion Mr
Abel it's great to get your insights on
the story we do appreciate it that is
Dan albelle joining us live from
Washington D.C
thank you